we might be drunk we
might be drunk as long as we
are hanging out you know we might be
drunk
raise a glass let's talk [ __ ] head peeps
wrecks and a bit
maybe drunk we might be
drunk
[Music]
hey here we are folks it's we might be
drunk
what's shaking good to see you man you
too it's summertime
uh it's boiling hot out there in
manhattan are you doing spots and shorts
later no
i got a [ __ ] tuxedo in my book bag
there but no i got jeans and a t-shirt
but i was wearing shorts all day and
then you put on jeans
it's one of these these months you need
a shower right when you leave the house
it's a lot of showering i hate it and
then you kind of over soap
yes now you're dry and flaky i hate it
thank god we're white or we'd be ashy
no offense to the jewish people but uh
wow i got an offensive black joke and
offensive jew joke in there
what um sorry but i know
i think we're on a show that later
tonight together stan
yeah yeah i'm on that one oh that's
usually pretty good all right yeah yeah
uh
what was i gonna say oh i had
oh yeah they say that the crime rises
with the heat
why is that well i think you're agitated
i think people are worked up like every
do the right thing and all these
movies like dog day afternoon it's
always like a heat wave
you know or or uh what's the son of sam
heat wave
interesting yeah maybe places like
alaska just have lower crime rates
oh detroit's got a very high crime rate
oh yeah and it snows there
yeah good point i don't know yeah nine
shootings
in 24 hours on july 4th crazy crazy and
it sucks because the fireworks confuse
you that's true
it's annoying right right and the the
pets hate it
the pets hate it my cat is on edge my
cat's like a meth head it's like a nom
nom vet it's annoying i was in the
the village and i'm leaving the cellar
and the dude just shoot they're like
shooting out fireworks
yeah they like almost hit me what people
got blinded that way
wow like in the the park right out of
ben's pizzeria
what yeah damn they were screaming at me
like get the hell out of here
what was it a bottle rocket or a roman
camera i couldn't differentiate oh yeah
such a you're a city guy all the way we
had bottle rockets out there
oh my god yeah we would hold roman
candles try to shoot each other
were any of the kids [ __ ] where they
would like like be like ah like they
tried to [ __ ] with you oh yeah oh yeah
and then there was always that one kid
with one finger missing and there was
one kid
did you have a friend with a scene oh
sure for sure one kid i knew would pop
him in his mouth
kids were nuts it was the 80s but yeah
good
time one time a kid threw a like a
cherry bomb at me
and i couldn't get out of the way and i
remember i looked down and it was on my
feet
like right at my feet and it didn't go
off and i was like oh it's a dud and
then i went pow and
my ears went and i thought i was deaf
but i was all right you're in a [ __ ]
you're in platoon all of a sudden
see guys in the distance like
dude uh yeah i'll tell you all right
speaking of that i gotta peeve
please wow we're coming out we haven't
even had the drink yet okay we'll pour
the drink
as i tell you because i'm excited i i
need a drink today
i got a weird one all right i'm going
all summertime blizzard i love
summertime bliss
i don't even know it's something
grapefruit huh oh yeah well it might be
blood orange this is a fizzly wine and a
can
i love it all right it's a spritz it's
basically an aperol
jesus christ i've never had it either
hey you've not tried this
no all right let's do it all right i
love this sound let's do it
sounds like my dad driving woo
got a scent that's good
oh yeah it's funky it is funky i feel
like about a pool in in
florida um
here's a peeve it's it's
gags where like i i don't get this as a
joke where it's like you and another
person and they [ __ ] with you and start
laughing like that's like a serial
killer to me that's not like oh yeah
like like the person where it's like
just you two and they have a bottle rock
and like ah
yeah and you're just like you got me i
guess right
you know what i mean it's like the joke
is on me because i i want to have both
my eyes
yeah yeah good point like you you
flinched i hate that guy who does that
and then i'd be like oh what are you
doing he's like oh you flinched i'm like
well yeah i thought you're gonna hit me
in the face
like what is this battle training having
a slice of pizza
i hate that and uh a [ __ ] friend of
ours did to me the other night
i'm gonna say his name too because i'm
mad at him right now all right vince
he's a friend of mine
but he does this [ __ ] i'm walking the
street i'm looking at my phone because
i'm trying to like see how much time i
have before i can make it to another
spot
and he just goes give me all your money
i'm like
and he's like you're racist and i'm like
you don't give me all your money is that
oh that's a bit that's a bit yeah and
he's got the mask up too he wears his
mask all the way up like was it
like you look like a robber right right
he wears all black also by the way and
the mask is up of course and he said
give me your money what do you want me
to do give me your money and then
and i was like ah he's like i got you
and i hit him and he was like he's like
what's your problem like i'm reacting
yeah that's that's not a bit it's not a
joke there's no twist
will does this where he'll do he thinks
this is funny
like he'll do jokes that just torment
you yeah like i remember one time
i was at the seller late one night i had
a gig the next day at the flyout for
he takes he takes my phone oh yeah
and my phone's got my wallet attached to
it so i've got like my credit cards and
[ __ ] so
i'm like is that someone see my phone i
don't know where i put it and everyone's
like oh [ __ ] literally everyone
seller is looking for my phone and it's
i sort of got an hour go by i'm like
[ __ ] i don't know what i'm gonna do i
guess i'm gonna have to like
borrow someone else's phone cancel all
my credit cards i'm gonna have to
print the boarding pass somewhere i
don't have a printer at home and after
like
literally an hour of me just being like
[ __ ] he's like got you and everyone's
like
why would you do that that's not i've
never heard the side of will this is
blowing my mind
i've done the road with will because we
used to do these gigs together and will
just he gets a kick out of [ __ ] with
you and like look sometimes it's funny
but sure but there is a time when i'm
just like that's not a joke you just
made me miserable for an hour
you took some of my time on earth and
you made it bad on purpose
yes yes man what a psycho i i had the
guy in high school would hit you in the
nuts
and he'd be like gotcha ah you're like
that's a pain it's painful
where where's the joke and that's when
it should end in high school in high
school it's like you're not a fully
developed person
it's annoying i hated this one too the
purple nurple they just like twist your
nipple and you're like
how about just having a conversation or
developing a personality
they can't do it they got nothing so
they have to resort to violence
and that's you they're getting a
reaction technically so i guess they
feel better
it's funny it's like have you seen any
movie you're the guy everyone hates
yes exactly you're the bad guy in every
movie i know the the
ear flick the purple nurple the credit
card swipe the credit card swipe i'll
take because it just go
you go whoa it's not like a painful you
have credit card swipe
that's why i let it slide
[Laughter]
yeah yeah the the oil check the goosing
whatever you want to do
less than the the nipple thing is
actually painful
oh huge yeah that sucks i hate that
feeling so i'm with you i'm with you
that guy sucks well i love will but i
love will too but it drove
i it's not a gag no no no no and i could
see the phone hiding for like five
minutes
but an hour it was an hour that's
exciting looking under
like looking under chairs like maybe
it's slipped behind a thing and i'm like
jeez i'm so sorry guys
i had to apologize to the weight staff
for the comedy show but here we are
talking about it
although wait actually that's my peeve
that guy you know we're also talking
about hitler
a lot too by the way here we are talking
about it so it must be something
no no it sucks we talk about bin laden
all the time one of hitler's friends do
it for the story man
right exactly yeah yeah you know he made
a name for himself
damn this is pretty good the first sip
was weird but it's going down easier
it's uh this is these are dangerous yes
because this doesn't
it tastes like a soda it really does
yeah this is a nice hot summer day drink
which it is
i can't tell if the
can look is classy or feminine
i think it's pretty feminine all right i
don't think we look cool drinking these
no now they're thin and pink
all right i thought you were going
somewhere with that one
like my dick that shirt it looks okay
with the shirt okay
because you're wearing a hawaiian you're
wearing like the
like chill guy sunglasses the shirt you
can get away with
that's true yeah yeah i'm like my name's
chad
i hit a jewel you know i'm on my dad's
boat
i have one you know what the the big one
is those big swans the inflatable swans
feels like every hot girl has a photo on
an inflatable swan
what is that it's huge now everybody's
gotta one person did it they liked it
and now everybody's gotta do it
sheep something about really unfunny
gags you used to see these on the dating
apps would be like a girl with the
mustache glass
yes everyone's got the muscles wouldn't
it be funny if i had a mustache
not really no no that's offensive to to
trans people by the way
but yeah she's right it's just like
you're like all right if you had a
mustache
well we did a weird flip i think 2006
where quirky was somehow funny
i know it's just quirky and we had in
the 90s it was the jenny mccarthy was
considered funny like no she's just
[ __ ]
or farting or picking her nose that's
not comedy she's just a goofball weirdo
but it's not she's not funny yeah that
was that was a tough run oh
bad run she had an mtv sketch show yes
like empty mtv was like jenny mccarthy
the logical
oh she's shown her tits in magazines she
should be the next uh
yeah yeah she's the next mel brooks over
here and look yes i jerked off to the
sketch show
but did you really yeah i thought she
was a hot number back in the day
yeah i mean her tits were always out she
was like a ditzy hot blonde no she i
definitely thought she was hot as a kid
yeah but she's gone off the deep end now
yeah
anti-vaxx or anti-autism anti-vaxx
yeah beforehand before corona
yeah i don't think she's a nice person
nah nah and i think she [ __ ] jim
carrey up a little bit i think did she
yeah they date they dated
damn that's gotta be rough because he's
gotta he's gotta pretend she's funny
oh that's gotta be right like he's
bringing heat all day
and then she's like and he has to be
like it's good
yeah it's good stuff you did you are hot
you are hot and you farted
right right i get that that goes against
type
right right and if anybody's like you're
not funny she's like uh jim carrey said
i'm funny
he's like oh you mean the guy you're
[ __ ] that's a tough one
yeah that is tough he was that was peak
jim carrey yeah
that was nine like jim carrey in the 90s
i rewatched the mask recently and like
that's a great example
of a not very good movie where the guy
is so good
so good that you're just like it's it's
worth it yeah
that's true in a young cameron diaz
first movie first movie she really
fought her way into that when i heard
really yeah
and boy it paid off how'd she fight her
way
well like she wouldn't take no for an
answer she would like
it's okay when a woman does it
[Laughter]
but yeah give that a go that was the
pamplemoose talking pamplemoose
i don't even know what a pamplemoose is
but i like it it sounds like an old
private jet in the 40s
i flew here on a it isn't it just
spanish or grapefruit pamplemoose what
is it i don't know i've never heard of
pampers
i think they're a indie band in brooklyn
i think that's the
grapefruit lacroix if i'm not wrong
pamplemoose can we look that up
what is it what is the translation oh
nice well i'm not cultured i just have
had that lacroix
ah
[Music]
luxembourg
wow i didn't know they had their own
language in lux
that's what we're doing right now
brother yeah pam we're pamplemoose and
it's a verb now
what a decent racial slur a couple of
pamplemoose
cut me off in traffic
by the way no one's more racist than
behind a wheel you know it could be
anybody
if they cut you off you're like of
course it's a mexican that's not even a
stereotype but
whatever it is you go with it that's
[ __ ] it's true man i used to have a
bit about like whatever
whatever person you pull up to you're
like i knew it
oh there you go yeah there you go like
uh
i mean i'm a terrible [ __ ] driver
though oh true have you been a car with
me
i have i never got in because i heard
the story yeah
i'm pretty bad i heard i heard colin
quinn and david tell david tell is
horrible
new york people are bad drugs yeah yeah
that's true
you think with brooklyn though he would
be all right new york people that grow
up in the city are not good drivers
yeah any people that grew up in any city
are pretty bad right
right well i gotta tell you i didn't
have any spots last night so i texted
liz like hey if you got anything let me
know
she goes well you should open for quinn
that is whatever he's doing the fat
black and i said
i'm in so 15 minutes in front of quinn i
got there early we hung out
i go on they're a hot crowd he goes on
and
it i mean i don't want to blow it out
but i've watched everything he's ever
done
his new hour is the best one what best
one yet
he tackles everything it's it's topical
it's current
it's relevant it's amazing he hits it
from all angles
i can't wait yeah he's he is the best
and uh
if you haven't seen his stuff it's on
netflix like long story short or
uh red state blue state all that stuff
yeah so new york story
new york story's incredible that one's
incredible i saw that on a date years
ago
live at the cherry lane theater i think
i saw it with my mom and we had a family
emergency and she like
walked out and it was from the back so
she had to like walk all the way through
during his opener
it was like brutal my mom is [ __ ] up
quinn's opening
right here terrible remember this story
where uh matteo lane
i don't know he had like he had to take
a [ __ ] or diarrhea and he had to walk
out
and quinn clocked it and he said they
brought it up like
for five years after yeah i remember
that goddamn porn mateo
that's uh yeah quinn is that that's good
to hear because man if you haven't
watched this stuff
you're missing that like literally
everyone i told to watch it is like that
was
incredible yeah if you can get past the
mumble mouth and the marble mouth i mean
he's he's the guy
he's the best he gave he uh so tom papa
married our our good friend rachel
feinstein and
her husband pete and tom papa a great
comic
marries them then quinn comes up right
after tom papa to give a speech and goes
your
your minister energy is really
infuriating everybody
and it kills and then tom goes on after
him and goes
you're right i should have mumbled
through my speech like you did and that
killed it was like man
comics at a wedding just [ __ ] hitting
each other yeah
it was great two pros two vets yeah and
that's a big gig because you're in front
of so many comics
it's brutal yeah it's almost like open
mic energy except
except they're rudin for you right no
one wants a wedding bomb
good point good point yeah if it's funny
they will laugh they'll give it to you
whereas an open mic if you're funny they
might not give it to you we've
been there where were you last weekend
i'm opening another
get a pomplamoose i was in uh phoenix
arizona
and it was great were you tempe or stand
up live
there's a new place called copper blues
live [ __ ] cancelled at the beginning
of the pandemic i canceled on that one
well if you go back you're gonna
sell out because we had a million alkies
there
oh yeah i love it it was great when sam
coming i never i never miss a week blah
blah blah this is a fun podcast
oh yeah new york you got to subscribe to
the new youtube if you're listening yeah
if you're listening to this on the
podcast app
or if you're watching here glad you're
here but you got it you got to get on
this uh
new youtube channel thank you to matt at
gotham studios for setting that up
salacuse our main man in studio with us
now oh yeah on the ones and twos and uh
hey have you got any packages send them
to gotham 3938
street 39 west 38th street gotham
studios send them here
yeah and uh yeah
great great comedy town phoenix gets
forgotten as one of these comedy towns
but
yeah one of the best crowds i mean dark
[ __ ] they don't get upset
they love it they root for it they get a
little hammered
oh yeah but uh great time and it's like
a hundred
it's like the capital of the world oh
the cougars
west coast florida leathery hot
big fake jugs that's what i said i said
the
the flag of scottsdale should be a milf
and a golf cart
going to pilates i mean it is
crazy out there it's just dentist wives
you know with nothing to do but
do uh yoga and sit by the pool damn
yeah there are i remember i did a gig
once in scottsdale and a guy had a
stroke during my set
what yeah brutal heat stroke
a stroke whoa yeah i was that's a bomb
holy [ __ ] what was it stand up
scottsdale which like so we used to do
this
i've ever told you this no but you got
to tell them about stand up scottsdale
well this club all right
if you don't know this club stand up
scottsdale's run by this guy howard
hughes who's a super nice guy
i think he was an ex-marine yes that's
right he was super supportive of comedy
but he
would get [ __ ] up yeah yeah and he
would do time
he would do like 25 minutes 30 minutes
before you oh yeah and it was like
dab it was shooting back and forth
between like edgy
like bill hicks type [ __ ] and then being
like you're not drinking you need a
drink
we need to make money for our venue so
this place was on bar rescue
yeah yes to put them on the map
that's crazy so they have this
incredible venue
and john taffer i guess tears at the
shreds and he's like what the [ __ ]
you're an idiot you're not good at
running it yeah music i'll turn it
around i get there and i remember being
like
you know it's a beautiful room yeah and
the shows were pretty good
but then i end up coming back and no one
tells me this he just picks me up and
i'm like oh it's a different hotel he's
like oh it's connected to the new venue
and i was like new venue uh-oh
it's the back of a mexican restaurant
yeah so i'm like well these are gonna be
different shows than i
anticipated you know and we get there
and uh
first night he gets like blackout drawn
yeah like and he was like
he's like just i got to get out of here
my uh my my girlfriend i was like dude
you gotta chill for a second yeah so he
stays for a little bit he goes on
and it's like all right yeah that it
doesn't go great whatever
he's by the way had a stroke before i
know this oh really yeah he like but he
got it from like cocaine and red bull he
didn't
it's not like a stroke story where
you're like you poor bat it's like
you're an idiot
right right you did too much coke and uh
i'm on stage and i'm doing pretty well
and this guy like knocks over a beer i
was like i guess i'm killing pretty hard
and she goes no
he's having a stroke oh and i was like
oh [ __ ]
stop the show i said i yell someone call
an ambulance so howard
uh calls an ambulance then i was like we
gotta do something and
howard takes he thinks do something
means go on stage and do schtick
so he's talking to the guy like so where
are you from i'm like he's having a
stroke you're gonna
force him to do back and forth
so give us a place we should be hospital
er oh my god that's insane
brutal and then uh how far in are you
cause like 20 minutes oh right in the
gooey middle
brutal and they were good uh i mean he
wasn't he was
in that shape but they basically call an
ambulance and the guy
he gets taken out and gives us like a
thumbs up that he's okay we're like
thank god
and then howard's like what do you want
to do i was like well i gotta finish i
can't like they're all here still
yeah so i give it like i was like let's
give it five minutes i start riffing i
just start
[ __ ] on howard for like 10 minutes
straight and it's
crushing like i can't follow materials
killing so hard
right right because they're all like
this guy's a [ __ ] idiot
wow but he did to his credit he took
it yeah and he was he always was a good
guy he would just get too drunk
sure but i think that's a pro move i
mean as the owner of a club you got to
respect even though you're taking the
hit
the crowd is happy a guy had a stroke
and they're still laughing
i mean that's that's a credit to you i
think uh you got to have tipped a hat to
that
new york headliner he also
so he's on bar rescue and then he's on
the bar rescue redemption show so it's
live
and they're like all right we want to
see how the bar is looking now
you know after we helped it revisit it
and it was like howard's not doing a
good job
whatever and you know
his nose is bleeding everywhere well
they i
just remember how john taffer you know
that show bar rescue was like
i'm not going to insult this man he's a
marine he's an american hero and you
know something bad is coming after that
yeah
he's building up but this man doesn't
know how to run a bar
and and i just remember howard getting
in his face like being tough getting in
his face and
one of his uh bar manager stands up and
goes
howard no they just kept replaying
howard no that was like the go-to
commercial and we're back
howard no wow
you got to pull that up i mean if i
better it's brutal
but it's like i was like oh yeah i play
and i always like the guy honestly
he's always a decent guy but uh those
are some memories i'm like
oh yeah i did that club like three times
because they would have me but no one
else would and for sure he was always a
tough
nut every time but he looked great he
was like 45 when i met him and he looked
like
28. and he'd a really hot cool girl yes
who was like a pilates instructor yes
exactly i hope he didn't blow her
because she was cool
yeah that's true but yeah he did he is a
handsome guy
and he's in really good shape great
shape full head of hair cool like cool
outfits
weird glasses yeah and you're right like
no one else would have and he really
appreciated us like i don't know
i remember i'd do a late night set and
he'd he would like promote it yeah
that's right he was right he was the
type of guy who like i felt like
it's gonna sound [ __ ] up but i felt
seen yeah
no well back in the day you took
anything any like compliment any like
booking meant the world to you because
it was so bleak
if he got like a good partner to run a
place with it would be good because he
really did care
he needs a yin and a yeah he's the fun
crazy guy i'll go on stage i'll do drugs
whatever
you need the the business guy it's not
yeah that's not the business guy
no no no i remember he was so so savvy
business-wise that he wouldn't
book a feature so they'd have like six
open mics hang open bikers hang out in
the green room and he would go
you you and you do six minutes and he
called a guest set so he'd have to pay
him
i hope he never hears this we love you
howie we do i mean you know what he
really was a good guy yeah yeah good guy
smart guy cool guy yeah weird guy
but so the weekend was killer copper
blues is awesome oh
dude great sold out a merch in like the
first show and a half
killer crowds really like grateful to
see you
you know they know it's a cross-country
travel for us and
just good good guys good hang fun
couples
great time it's looking like november
for phoenix for me if you're if
you are asking when i'll be there so i
will be there by the way that john
taffer was terror that guy's a tough guy
he's not easy yeah i mean i've seen him
go up to like
you know some guy had a jazz club in
harlem and it's a big black guy and he
was like
you suck you're a shitty businessman
your food sucks your wife's fat you're
ugly and the guy was like i'm gonna kick
your ass and he's like do it
do it i'm like this guy's got balls or
he knows like hey i'm on tv and i got
eight security guys behind me
well it's also like you're just you know
that it's gonna get publicity
he punches him in the face he's like
good i'll get [ __ ] yeah that's true
that's true he's a big dude too yeah
he is a big guy it's kind of like gordon
ramsay he says some [ __ ] i'm like damn
man this guy's got feelings but then you
see his tick-tock with his daughter and
you're like hey he's probably a good dad
i mean he does seem like an [ __ ] that
some people it's like you know what
simon cowell really popularized
being the [ __ ] you're right and
especially with british guys they get
away with murder
i know but like it's like every show
just was like well this is
anytime something succeeds they're like
well this will be our model this is an
archetype
and then it became the [ __ ] the the
uh
the guy who keeps it real yeah the
kindly woman
like yeah that was that was a black guy
yeah i remember
at the comic strip the comedy club like
i started it started at
they did that for the audition is that
right they were like well the guy who
was the booker he's like i'll be the
[ __ ] yeah like
you're just [ __ ] with a like this is
such a low level at least like simon was
[ __ ] with people on tv and it was a
show
this is just for you right right
that's true i remember watching american
idol in college when it was like new and
the biggest show on tv
and i'd be sitting in like a girl's
apartment and they all loved him they
were like he's so hot
he tells it like it is he's british he's
mean they loved him
i thought he was gay not
gay he uh british yeah anytime
yeah it is it was a bold move too to
rock the muscle shirt when yeah
when you're not like really that in
shape that's true he had some some guns
though
yeah probably yeah i mean if that dude
doesn't have a physical trainer what are
you doing with your money
when you're worth that much money if you
don't have a dude helping you good point
it's it's weird when guys have huge like
i remember i rewatched whiplash
and jk simmons has huge guns in it which
i guess
adds to the dominance of you know his
whole character is about like
he's fear yes exactly that's a great
movie
great movie i love how much you love
movies oh dude i just rewatched serpaco
you got to see it i haven't seen
surprise ever it's not crazy it's like
talk about
the quintessential new york movie i mean
salaccus wouldn't be here without
serpico
it's incredible and pacino my god pacino
he rules man oh especially 70s pacino
godfather afternoon come on
dog day afternoon is so good so good
attica attica yeah and it's good they
really used new york back then it was
like
very brooklyn-y yeah something about
those old movies that like
old new york movies and i kind of like
like think about even movies like uh
jeez why is this movie midnight uh
cowboy
oh yeah they could go dark they went
dark you're right
and like an ending didn't have to be
super no like i hate to give spoiler
[ __ ] but i didn't have to be super
upbeat like
right i like old movies where they could
just end in a shocking way and you're
like that's the that's the movie
yeah good good call it's funny you say
that because i'm a big tarantino nut and
he was just on rogan
so i listened to that immediately and he
said the 70s was
amazing i heard him on bill maher oh
yeah he said the same thing about the
like in in 60s yes and then the 80s were
like
happy you know karate kid and it's gotta
have a happy ending and it's families
and suburbs and then the 90s was like
pulp fiction and
all these dark knight 90s were good
great great you know saving private ryan
or like boogie nights
boogie nights fargo fargo come on
yes la confidential exactly or even
even like the matrix was like whoa what
this is great yeah so uh
i think it might have with comedy i mean
we kind of went into this weird way with
comedy quirky
and cutesy and safety and all that and i
think maybe we're going the other way
we made a good point too with some of
that we always think of the 60s as being
the greatest decade for film but then
like
it's not until the late 60s it's true
bonnie and clyden and graduate are like
late
like 68 yeah that's good that's a good
point
and then 70s it just got crazy like peck
and paw and all this
other [ __ ] but uh 70s so is the 70s the
best decade for film
i think so i think so but when is
midnight cowboy
six late 60s yeah late 60s so that's
really when it flipped
all right we're geeking out sorry guys
we go in the movie
rex a lot i got a good wreck for you
okay hit me mayor of east town
ah i watched the first uh two today it's
or yesterday it's amazing great show
great show i mean
the woman is a huge cruise but
yeah but she's i guess she's been
through a lot like she's like got zero
appeal like if you knew her you'd be
like oh this lady sucks yeah but that's
what i like about it
uh-huh how many how many schlubby male
pis do we see
that i can't think of one schwabby
female pi in film can you imagine i
think that's
exactly her pitch where's the where's
the female
but never
this is just her have you seen it oh you
have okay
do you like it yeah it's really well
done
it's realistic yeah and and that's the
whole thing is that she does
and she's still attractive though i mean
oh yeah it's like that's the thing where
you're like there aren't that many
female roles like this where you see a
really
uh purposely you know
as you said yeah well
she's she's kind of mean she's you know
like the new guy zabel
coming in he's like all right i'm just
trying to be your friend like take it
easy and you're like
i get it well she clearly hasn't been
through therapy yeah yeah
her son i don't want to say too much but
his son is dead and divorced and all
this [ __ ]
you know she's [ __ ] up a case so
she's got a lot on her plate but uh
yeah that's the first time seeing a
woman in that position
yeah you don't see i think about like
every male pi like colombo schlubby as
hell
yeah like like almost every kojak's not
exactly a looker you know
right like every male pi is kind of like
yeah
i'm even trying to think of like classic
female detectives i think like a marisha
hargitay
from law and order and she's super hot
other than that it's uh
angela lansbury and murder not exactly
not a lot of edge for sure she's like a
you know tea time but a typewriter
for sure but yeah you're right you're
right and then she [ __ ] the guy and
he's like
let's get dinner and she's like ugh it
was a one-time thing
guy pierce yeah man they uglied him up
he was a hunk
oh i think he looks pretty good what but
the bad gray
oh man i don't know i mean he's hey man
he's
50 something i mean okay how old is guy
beer look at him in memento
and then look at him now it's it's a
train right he's had a good career
great career i like confidential
momentum 53.
i thought he was 78. he looks like 78
mark
178 year old who's got a head of hair
like that he looks like
ben franklin in that movie or in that
show franklin he looks
nothing like ben franklin i don't know
he looked like a founding father
it is a hilarious character the one hit
wonder it's like that that's okay
that relationship you're like would this
have happened like that's what i was
gonna say
that's the only there's a couple things
in the show that i don't love like that
why would he like her well i just don't
even know why they would like each other
like they're just so different
like you know he's kind of this like
he's like this my uh my book just came
out uh
or you know my my lecture and she's just
like i've got to murder the deal
like is that is that working in any way
yeah that's true that's true
yeah and then i guess she likes him
cause she's like wow a man is attracted
to me and he's
a smart guy or whatever yeah but
him i can't figure out maybe he likes
him yeah the brooding well she's
attractive
she's attractive but i think it seems
like he's into more than that about her
i don't know and there's also uh yeah he
likes her he's
i mean look he's an artist he's damaged
he probably has to
he probably wants a little damage good
point good point and
and probably keeps thinking i mean he
has writer's block right failed writer
at this point not fail he's got his book
but he's written a book in 25 years so
he's probably like this maybe this will
give me something
[Laughter]
good see that's the turn you know a lot
of people be like hey we need a woman in
this role but they'll still
want you to be hot she's like no no we
gotta go all the way and i respect that
yeah it's it it makes more sense for the
character like you see a character
normally she would have like six-pack ab
right
would this be in east town would this be
yeah exactly how this person looked
yes also she's not charlize theroning
and uh scarlett johansson where they're
like kicking eight guys ass in a room
it's real yeah i love that the first
scene she's like limping and she twists
her ankle
it's kind of real exactly which
yeah i like that about it the one thing
i'm not crazy about like
i love the daughter who plays like you
know the the honor student daughter
at the good school with the shaved head
she's great she's the girl and nice guys
thank you she's great nice guys
she's even good in this but the
character is just so kind of
underdeveloped i think
and um it's like of course
like it's you know like all her friends
she's like got like the gay guy like all
that yeah
i'm like do these characters exist in
east town that felt a little forced
it felt like an hbo exec like who was in
like you know who like hasn't been
anywhere but los angeles
in the last 20 years was like the
daughter's gay she's got a weird haircut
yeah and and the girlfriend's got to be
black like we need a black girlfriend
and they hit all the boxes with one
character like get up
there what's that
[Laughter]
so somebody write that one down no but
it's it really it really is like
you know they had to overdo it yeah okay
fine but it's it's always like i feel
like almost every show now is like we
have to represent everything
yes yes which is impossible because
every time kate
winslet's down on screen i'm just like
this show is taking a hit
i agree she's the show she is really a
great actor
unbelievable you believe she's that lady
all the way that's another thing
hacks you watch the show hacks now we're
just getting into [ __ ] tv guide over
here yeah yeah
hacks is good it's really like i can't
do any more comedy it looks great i just
can't do any more stand up there's not a
lot of stand up in it which
i'm with you i'm with you but the the
joan rivers character by gene smart
who's also a mayor
is so good so good and like open i
opened for schumer for years so it's
like these weird parallels a lot there
like a powerful
strong rich woman opener uh but
the end it's so good i messaged the
producer i was like this is great this
is really good and she wrote me back
like thanks i appreciate it
and blah blah blah but the end it gets
all preachy and there's a message and i
feel like it ruined it
preachy's tough in any yeah it's a
comedy show and i get it there's heart
you can have heart but it felt like a
forced message and that's when they lost
anytime i feel like a joke i'm telling
is more message than funny i dropped the
joke like sometimes a joke is getting
more applause and laughter and you're
like
that's not a joke that's a [ __ ] point
i'm a comedian
geez yeah i do do you know this bit
i had a bit where i said it was about uh
freedom of speech you know what i'm
talking about you remember this bit well
yeah i cut it from the roof i said
something about like uh how this guy got
fired from going on a racist tirade i'm
a little buzzed so
i didn't i should have eaten something
pamplemoose this pamplemoose
part of me pardon me but the pamplemoose
uh
do you remember the bit it was like how
a guy was going like a racist tirade and
he got fired cause someone videotaped
yeah you can't say anything anymore i'm
like well you did say it
you did say it right uh it's like you
just thought you should have gotten away
with it that was a bit and what would
you remember the next line
something about uh
yeah yeah you did you said it for an
hour and a half on the line on railroad
you said the n-word for an hour and a
half and he's like
what was the next put uh yeah you did it
for you did it for
you did it it was kind of funny you did
it first it's funny that part makes it
funny you did it for an hour and a half
you did it for half a godfather
length movie you know but i don't
remember the turn there was like one
more line but it was
it was getting more nods and laughs and
that's not
that's not a joke you want to laugh with
a nod yeah yeah
exactly it i don't remember how it went
but i it i cut it out because i was like
it's
it's it's hitting in woke circles but
it's not hitting in the other
i want jokes to hit everywhere yeah here
here and i felt like it was like a woke
point where i was also kind of being
because i'm not for the a person losing
their life i don't i don't believe in
that
right i think people i think we don't
need to be more accepting but we should
be more forgiving like i've said that
but i do think like in that joke it made
it sound like i was saying
well [ __ ] him right you did you know and
there was a part of me it's like what do
you think i mean this was like a real
story guy was just screaming the n-word
at people on the train like you're a
[ __ ] idiot but
the fact that like you can never work
again is also like
i think the angles that we're just not
gonna have racists have jobs anymore
like what are we gonna do with like
we're gonna lose so many big industries
you know oh that's a good
angle from it but it's more kind of like
hmm i don't remember the exact bit but i
remember
that's why i dropped it do you have any
bits like that ever where they applaud
and you're like [ __ ]
i did have so i can't think of them now
but i've definitely had i had a whole
bit about
everybody's full of [ __ ] they'll just
slap a rainbow sticker on a bazooka
and they kill like 80 you know 80 000
people but they're like
but come on i'm inclusive you know or
something like that
yeah maybe it is a bit yeah there's
something there that's something there
any time a bit feels like it's getting
applause in the setup
oh yeah yeah you kind of have a problem
right right right right
definitely i i don't want them i'm not
up there like
i would never like take for granted like
they're not here to listen to me
like like make points yeah and it's easy
to agree it's easy to go racism is wrong
or
uh you know murder is bad everybody's
like yeah it did the cops murder people
that's bad
oh yeah like all right anybody can do
this the talent is the twist
and the turn and the finding the funny
and the mining the humor
for sure it's like when someone goes on
stage and it's like i think gay should
be allowed to get married and you're
like
we're in manhattan like yeah did you
think you were going to get pushback
right exactly trans people shouldn't be
beaten you know like i know nobody
should be beaten
get out of here i think it'd be funny if
you went the other way and you're like
that's funny i think women should be
allowed to vote and everyone's like what
right right right like yeah we can vote
and you're like well i think that's
that's a good thing yeah but tell me why
women can't vote
and make that funny now we're cooking
yeah it's funnier to take something
that's wrong yeah of course that's
comedy yeah
i wish i remember the bit i think once a
bit stops working i just flush it out of
my head completely
daniel taj has this great bit he has a
special that doesn't get any love that i
think is amazing well you know why
it's on comedy central like no one
watches it no one watches
good boy no one watches their specials i
think you're gonna say something
horrible well you know why he did this
or that i'm like oh it doesn't come out
of a child that's why that would still
get some hits
but yeah he's got this great special and
he has this bit about uh
how like the positives of 9 11. which
immediately the audience is like uh-oh
and he makes it work and he tiptoes
through it and it kills
and i'm like that is artful that was
masterful that was comedy
interesting i have a bit where i defend
pedophiles now oh
i just say here's what i like about
pedophiles they never complain about my
jokes
like i've never i've never had one stand
up mid pedo joke and go
enough right you know so i think that i
like that angle where it's like
of course i don't really defend them but
the crowd [ __ ] knows that
yes i'm doing jokes you know who doesn't
defend pedos uh openly
pedos they're scared yes
exactly there's no union
[Laughter]
although they'd have good snacks that's
true that's true
you guys like goldfish you know who else
likes goldfish
the people were trying to get to attend
these meetings with us
yeah pedo is also who's you know
sometimes you don't want to watch your
kids
they'll watch them all right i can never
get this one bit to work about
pedos about like that afterwards parts
got to be rough where they're like
oh i love this i could never get this to
work about like which show to watch the
kids like i want to watch
peppa pig and they're like i'm more of a
crown guy i don't really know
right right never could get that to work
ever yeah talk about like you know you
have a one-night stand
and then you you realize that you're
kind of different talk about how
different a pedophile would be with this
kid
should we get tacos kids like i want
graham crackers like oh great
i need someone with a more sophisticated
palette i just
yeah what do you want to listen to led
zeppelin rafi
we're seeing we're uh we're eating tacos
we'll listen to that song again
yeah right right i got to give you a
peeve here
please give me and maybe a wreck
although my wreck is so uh
cheesy i love it i love a cheesy recipe
all right
well first of all the peeve and this
rolls right into uh what we're talking
about is
the person who makes uh maybe an
off-color irreverent joke
and the eye you get the eye roll from
the guy who knows you're joking but is
still like
i don't approve of this i had that in
the green room
that person's mother yeah yeah exactly
yeah
you know we'd be like uh there was a we
had a female host and she was really
funny savannah
and uh i said something and she was like
oh sorry i'm late i was in the kitchen i
was like that's where women belong you
know
joking and the guy rolled his eyes like
the sound guy and i'm like you work in a
comedy club
what are we doing here i know this gal
we're friends what are you crazy
give me the eye roll also i think women
i'm just saying i think women should be
gainfully employed
the kitchen is a is a place where people
can work and it's a hard time to find
jobs right now
i like going like really hard you know
it's i hate those people you're like
i'm clearly [ __ ] around i know i know
and then it's weird that you have
certain places
it's all comes back to history like if
you go i believe a woman's place is on
the stage of a comedy club it'll go good
for you but if you go i believe
there are places in the kitchen be like
whoa i'm like well what's the difference
what if she loves cooking do you see
what i'm saying for sure
ah the eye roll it's tough when it's a
job that isn't as desirable
i guess i guess that's the message i
believe a woman's place is the ceo of a
fortune 500 company that's cool
that's cool but if it's a if it's like i
believe a woman's place is uh
yeah cooking is not yes mopping up
or whatever but but the thing with
cooking is like this michelin chefs his
five-star
restaurants like it's an honorable job
you're like look at bourdain he's
you know loved yeah and dead and dead
good point and a heroin addict but it is
interesting
whatever like like if you got a a
calendar in your
your house with tits on it and they're
like jeez well all right you sexist pig
and i'm like oh they're trans they're
like
oh great i love it i love it
oh maybe that could be a bit it's just
funny how it's okay when it's like a
a marginalized thing or whatever i don't
know it's it's all very silly
yeah there was a pho you either it's
like you're either pervert or
progressive you flip it on them real
quick
there's something about uh that's a hot
chick whoa easy creep that's a hot fat
chick
hey all right this guy's open-minded my
of stuff still being shallow my bit this
week has something to do with that uh oh
uh oh no it's not closing you want me to
do your rack first
okay okay okay my wreck is dumb but it's
uh actually
i do it every day so i shouldn't say
it's dumb but it's not a movie it's not
a song
morning and night i think it'll really
improve everyone's life
eat a banana every morning
and plank for a minute every night just
plank once a night
a minute i know it sounds like a [ __ ]
but you're gonna sit on the couch anyway
you're gonna sit on your phone anyway
sit on your phone
while planking and a minute it'll fly by
damn it
it's good for the core it's good for the
back it's good for the uh the spine
give it a shot one minute we are brought
to you by sheath
underwear this keeps your ball off your
leg two pouches one for your dick one
for your balls
keeps the ammo separate from the gun
this is great underwear i actually use
this
this is my girlfriend's favorite
underwear this gets me laid
this underwear supportive sexy looking i
really do
this is my favorite underwear i'm not
just saying this i'm not just saying
this because they're paying us money i
really
think there's quality underwear uh the
idea from sheath came from the founder
u.s army soldier robert padden during
his second tour in iraq
are you guys going to support the troops
award support this awesome veteran-owned
company who's founder
he's a big comedy fan he's messaged me
he's a great dude i know he's messaged
you too
go to sheath underwear dot com and order
with promo code drunk
to get 20 off your first order and
sheath
underwears 100 money back guarantee that
sheath underwear dot
promo code drunk get sheath underwear
and let them support
your balls that's good a banana and a
plank banana to plank not the end of the
world and you're already moving in the
right direction
and this is very manageable bananas are
cheap put them on top of the fridge
and then you go ah [ __ ] i'm going to bed
60 seconds
knee or elbows and toes funny how many
exercises are named after
uh ways you could die oh like you walk
the plank you die
what are you calling you you do those
runs suicides
oh yeah what else
[Music]
you could choke on something i guess
yeah
yeah what else is there a guillotine or
a hangman
yeah what else is there exercising
elliptical
well you know what's funny to say that
is the uh the treadmill was invented in
england to be a torture device
and now it's uh you know we do it
willfully
i mean barely yeah it isn't [ __ ] hate
exercising man
yeah it's just so funny that we're like
all right i got to get my steps in and
they're like oh no
they're taking me to the treadmill
there's got to be a bit there so now we
pay for it yeah i wonder do you think
people will pay for like other
torture devices right right like maybe
uh
what's the one with you will they
stretch you you know
and now we pay to get like you know
stretch the yoga
i'm getting the clans what's that well
it used to be a water board but they
actually
it clears you out right right so yeah
and the chair oh interesting
great pulse the pulse alley and then
also you have like what's the one the
brazilian the dance one
uh capoeira what does that mean
well it doesn't mean anything but it
used to it's like it's they have these
dark origins like
capoeira comes from like these brazilian
slaves
they would like disguise it as a dance
so their slave owners didn't think they
were doing anything and then they turned
into a martial art so they'd
they'd [ __ ] up their slave owners wow
which is hilarious that they're just
watching like yeah they're pretty good
dancers
they just start killing you i like the
idea of that now like i got twerked to
death
that's how she escaped if i see a woman
twerking though i'd pretty help
yeah that's pretty good oh man it is
hilarious how much of instagram or like
tick tock
it's just a woman like shaking her ass i
don't know and you're just like this is
your skill
right you could have picked anything and
you just went with ass yeah and have you
tried to twerk
oh god incredibly hard i mean you want
me to try it
i mean i can't even do it it's not even
worth the let's see you twerk
[Music]
damn not even not even uh
i look good the butt has to like really
move so fast that the
the fat part of it it can't keep up i
don't know i've really studied the
the art of twerking it's it's a weird
one any dance
looks easy and then you're like that's
[ __ ] work i know women dancing is
very attractive
i guess that's why strip clubs became a
thing man strip
the older i get the more i'm just like i
can't get into it i don't like them
either it's not
it's just like i think about the lady
and then you feel like if you're not
tipping enough she's pissed at you
and then you're like am i getting a
cheap am i being cheap here
i don't know yeah it's not my thing no
i'm with you
tick tock salad you you nailed tick-tock
i'm not even on tick-tock
but ever before i'm what i've seen like
i do i mean everybody likes it but i
just know i'll stare at it for six hours
by the way tick tock while you plank
that'll solve that
but it's good it's just women with
outfits like tight outfits going like oh
in the mirror or whatever and you're
like why am i watching this it's because
you want to look at women all day
but you can't stare at a woman in the
street because then you're a weirdo
but you're allowed to do it here yeah
that's why [ __ ] people who are just
like staring at women on public transits
like well you don't have social media
what are you homeless that's the good
point yeah that's a great point
of the population now that's double the
views interesting yeah
there's something about uh it's so
hilarious the way you say
tick-tock why you playing you're like a
cool uh fitness instructor
you're like a cool dad or something you
could guys we need to get you guys in
shape
all right remember you could uh scroll
twitter while you do this you could uh
i'm trying to it's when i got braces as
a kid i remember they were like no
sweets i was like oh my god
and the lady took me aside she's like
you can have a piece of cake
but just wash your mouth out after with
water
i don't live my life like this but of
course every kid ends up eating you know
five pounds of cake still oh cake man ah
good band cake a cake is a good banana i
love that band i mean that's basically
our intro right
oh yeah good point good point yeah what
uh give me uh
what's your oh your record's a banana
what's your bit
oh my bit okay now this one needs some
work but i think there's something i
tweeted just the premise and it got over
100 retweets so i
think there's something here but i can't
crack it these are almost the hardest
kind of bits where it's
obvious that it's a bit so the pressure
to make it funny
is more and then i can't think of it
yeah you know when a bit is weird it's
almost easier to think of the
funny but uh when it's good in the setup
it's hard to
it's hard to crush that second part
because it's you
you've in some ways peaked it joe oh no
anthony devito has a great
joke where he's like my mom is
blind and she's dating a black
hairdresser
and whatever and he's like i've never
felt more pressure to write a bit yeah
he made a bit out of how hard it is to
make that a bit i love that bit
that is genius but um all right so i was
really hung over the other day
and i realized the way you are when
you're hungover is like a sneak peek
into how you're going to be as an old
person you can barely get out of bed
you're [ __ ] water
you're cranky you're hunched over you
know you regret everything and your
friends talk about you like you're old
like he doesn't remember much
you know and it's kind of getting
screwed he's getting chuckles
but uh it's not it's not going where i
needed to go and i tried a whole thing
about like
all my friends don't get hungover like i
do i'm a mess next time i get hungover
i'm gonna go to an old folks home
and just because i can relate to them
you know like i was shot at nom and i
was like i was taken down by shots too
you know but again it's okay i don't
know if it's taken down by shots
yeah there's something funny about uh i
mean
this may be too obvious but the idea
you're mumbling slurs like what was that
you're like it was a different time i
don't know oh
that's good like something about what i
did then
you know it was a different time yeah
you were drunk yeah yeah that's good
all right i like that i was a different
person yeah
yeah um oh that's good yeah i was a
different person then
i've evolved
right right yeah yeah yeah i mean when
you're hungover
like you're slower you have you know
energy you know you got no strength
you don't want to see your grandkids how
drunk did i get [ __ ]
oh yeah yeah you got to eat you're
eating when you're hungover you're like
i can't eat that when you're older you
can only eat a few things
so i really tried to find a lot of
parallels but
and it was i was trying on stage it was
doing okay but it wasn't
you know when you feel like oh this
bit's got legs maybe there could be
something funny about like you're in a
diner alone
oh
that's good that's good we're crossing
over
yeah you both woke up at 7am yeah and
you're like [ __ ]
both can't get it up
all right okay i think we got some here
you can't get it up it's funny
um yeah yeah wet myself
smell weird it needs a big finish yeah
but
i'll get there but yeah i couldn't i
couldn't crack it all right direction is
funny
maybe the erection racism is funny yeah
the uh yelling
i'm yelling at kids like i have a
playground next to my house and i was
like god these kids
are so loud this racket i have found
myself saying that
oh yeah even birds i'm like when i'm
hungover i'm like god the tweet tweet
i used to live right next to a
playground too and i was like i [ __ ]
can't ever jack off they're always
[ __ ] laughing
[Music]
that's a good sign i would jack it off
every day
i can't believe i lived next to this
place i'm not even allowed in it
all right what do you got on the bit uh
my [ __ ]
yeah your [ __ ] i wrote it down i had
some ideas so i gotta write it down
because i'm [ __ ]
well i don't know i just wrote this one
on the way here but i think there's
something to this
so i was reading this article on uh it
was in the new york times which
david brooks wrote this article about
like how if someone's tie
if someone's fired because of the color
of their skin it's racist you know if
it's because they're a woman
it's sexist but there's no recourse for
ugly people that was his whole
point oh so i want to kind of go off
this point my own way
yeah where it's like you know like well
i think the problem is
like it's because beauty is in the eye
of the beholder yeah you know i mean you
can't be like oh i got fire because i'm
not attractive and the judge is like
well i think you're attractive and
you're like well objectively i'm not
good looking yeah yeah i think so the
angle i think is like you can't
you can't put the boss in the stand
because that's where it gets weird it's
like uh
oh that's good under oath would you bone
her that's good
and they're like well there's no good
answer if you say no you get sued if you
say yes
you're fired right right that's good
that's one angle i had
then i wrote this down it's like it's
called lookism
that's when you when you you judge
someone based on how they look it's
called look ism
that sucks because that's just the word
you use for what you see
right right that's like that's like like
that's pretty messed up the way you used
your eyes
yeah you know what i mean like so this
is very the only
person the innocent is the blind guy
exactly
yeah they actually they make glasses for
this it's just uh yeah they just put
black uh sleeves over the
eyes yeah uh no you're right the blind
guys don't
even blind people touch your face oh
yeah even blind people were like let me
oh
[ __ ] you know yeah uh but then i had a
few angles for this i want to go one was
i think the more progressive we get
the more loopholes there's going to be
for people getting fired in the future
like like it's not my fault i got fired
you know i'm personality challenged
oh i think there's something they're
like how many excuses they're going to
be
right right oh yeah interesting
you know like you people are going to
get fired from the military it's just
[ __ ] up i got
i got discharged you know that i'm
[ __ ] bravery challenged you know
oh yeah right right how politically
correct are we gonna have to
be yes yeah you used to get fired forget
being gay
now it's gonna be everything it's
everything that's interesting and as an
excuse for everything
so this is my turn i took too long to
get here but this is my turn
because these are just notes i took but
i'll tell you who's the most inclusive
group
drunks cause drunks see beauty in
everyone
right sometimes i'm drunk and i look at
a woman that sober me didn't find the
beauty in and i pat myself on the back
yes right i'm like man when is the rest
of the world going to catch up
man that's a that's a big angle there's
something there that's big
because we call it beer goggles but we
all we also say hey see the beauty in
everything
but when i do you see i got beer goggles
maybe i'm just open-minded maybe
i'm just uh you know maybe i got a big
heart or whatever that's good i'm
inclusive i'm inclusive it's not beer
goggles i'm inclusive drunk people are
inclusive yes
this is why we can't you know
everybody's like how come alcohol is
legal and not weed because
booze makes you wouldn't be here without
booze i'm not inclusive when i'm high
yes when you're high you [ __ ] lock
the door i want to get the hell away
from people
that's interesting yeah something here
i'll correct you i love this
there's something here yeah i mean you
really uh really
cracked this open there's a lot here oh
yeah oh yeah it's very
it's not there yet at all but there's
something here well i think another
angle could be
uh you know looks are subjective
but all these other ones aren't like gay
black asian
men like that's not subjective but looks
are so that's the only one where you
can't
really call someone ugly because like
you said somebody will find you hot
well beauty privilege is like a thing
you know yeah
that is that's like weird that like no
one talks about that but if you're like
a hot
person like you haven't even easy life
of course because nobody wants to go i'm
ugly
no nobody wants to be that guy who's
like i'm calling it i'm ugly is that why
they don't march
yeah yeah the ugly parade would be
right there the ugly parade is like
yeah i have a joke about the baby march
because i have a joke about
but there's like a joke about uh [ __ ]
the ugly
yeah ugly people don't mobilize because
ugly people are like well i'm not gonna
meet anyone there
you know right right yeah
yeah that one makes sense yeah
but here's the turn they can have a fat
guy rascal off
they all just take scooters just 10
miles an hour
the the here's the turn sure it's an
ugly parade
but it's not ugly if you're drinking and
you bring it all back around
yeah then we just call it saint patty
there we go there we go here we go
they're ugly the irish are ugly
take that you mix all right i love the
irish redheads they're very
serious women are pretty good oh [ __ ]
freckles shiv
on us uh commission australian isn't she
i think she is but they could be irish
in australia maybe
but i mean what you see the trailer for
season three no
season three succession is coming dude i
cannot wait that's my turn
that's probably my favorite show you got
me hooked it took me two tries but man
once i got in i
really pushed you and guess what else i
pushed you to watch that you haven't
watched yet
oh i gotta do it i gotta do it rick and
morty yeah yeah
give it a shot i will do it it's so good
um
dude yeah succession's the best show the
best the best even at that theme song i
would be dancing in the living room
i've watched it i think i've watched it
all twice yeah
it's just so [ __ ] watchable i think i
have two yeah very
adult it's very um i don't say
subtle because it's not subtle but it's
like it's the perfect
amount of action in a show it's like not
game of thrones but it's not [ __ ]
downton abbey it's like
you're right and it's [ __ ] funny it's
funny it's
real it is arrested development as a
drama
oh you're right it's like it's rich
people
it's rich people who are [ __ ] up who
are conniving
and getting trying to get what they want
and it's a family who keeps kind of
[ __ ] each other over
yeah wow that's a great review a
wrestling development for
or for a drama
you're right mckay
he was on kevin hart's podcast he was on
my basketball podcast
yeah he's the best how was oh yeah i
think we talked about that already
but yeah he seems like the coolest i
love him he's great
what uh everyone's got a podcast now
conan pulls out a show to do a pod kevin
hart is a pod
obama has a pod obama's got a pod with
springsteen
isn't that the w what is this uh it's
this rush hour two or another 48 hours
here
is trump gonna start one with ted nugent
the hell's next
yeah right that would be kind of
entertaining
[Laughter]
trump's new segment all right we in this
segment we rank women based on their
looks
five four five
and every time he talks the nugenda hits
ring
it's a riff it's called the golden pony
oh man that would be good i have not
i've never i should probably listen i'm
kind of curious but i just i'm like i
don't give a [ __ ] what obama yeah i'm
kind of curious i think obama was good
and i don't want to ruin
it you know because it's going to be
like hey this is barack obama and he's
all
dignified and integrity and then he's
like dollar shave club
you got to get on it he i listened to
him on bill simmons podcast and they
were just talking basketball and it was
kind of cool oh really it's cool to hear
it's cool to have a president who
who is like into the nba yeah that is
pretty great
it's kind of fun that's pretty great i
mean we haven't had any fun with a
president since clinton did the
sax on arsenio you know and the sex
that wasn't the only time he was using
his fingers in the 90s that was
everywhere
but uh yeah it's funny like trump would
be trump's great because he would only
compliment athletes that were nice to
him oh really
like tom brady is one of the best
winners like you guys are just friends
right like he's like really his ego was
so big he'd be like i'll like you
if you tell me you like me yeah yeah
that's true he was really biased
and biden you're like this dude doesn't
watch any sport no maybe golf
maybe maybe a matlock yeah but that's it
right right oh boy
hopefully he makes it through the whole
presidency
you never know it's getting a little
weird with the speeches
and the the we saw him get down on one
knee with that woman who had all those
kids did you see that thing no
he got down on one knee and you're like
that's a [ __ ] that's a bold move for
a man his age to do it on camera
because like i get down on one knee it
might not be a graceful
right back up right but wow but when
you're pushing 80 to get down to one
knee
that's banana that's [ __ ] that's a
lot i can't believe he pulled a
kaepernick at this age
jesus christ biden what is he thinking
i can't believe the dog outlived him
well he got in [ __ ] for this
too because he got in [ __ ] because you
get down on one knee it was almost like
he was being like wow you've given birth
so many times
but but they're like well that's not
very feminist that you like think like
oh i have to get down to one knee for
this woman
can people do anything without people
just getting i know relax everybody
yeah yeah it's tough maybe he was like
that was his way of being like i bet
your [ __ ] hurts let me let my knee hurt
for a second can i can i have some
solidarity with you
right right a knee for a knee or a knee
for a
labia i don't know what the hell is it
my mom gave birth twice
tore the vagina butthole bridge
how nice twice yeah so i can't imagine
what did she give birth eight times
you said i think this person was you
look it up i think it was 12.
12. i just like abiding knee i mean that
undercarriage must be
just ruined like like a like a [ __ ]
skyscraper in miami
ah jesus christ sorry can we can we wait
til all the bodies are discovered before
we do this one well by the time this
comes out they'll be found
i'm sure
that was crazy because it was like uh i
i don't know the exact numbers on this
but the condor in miami it's like
they inspect buildings i think every 40
years and this one was like 39.
oh so they were going to inspect the
next two so i got an idea
39 years yeah yeah there you go
is that crazy wow they inspect the woman
every 20 years
all right but that was bad i don't even
know what that means i don't know what
either
my point is as as when a woman had the
joke with him down and it made me laugh
when a woman is in her in miami at 39
they've already given up
[Music]
thank you bye i've been drinking papal
boos
this is this is good yeah i think you're
gonna like what i bring in next week
okay you've inspired me all right a lot
of sugar a lot of sugar
what are we going to do man yeah all
right well do we go
short i'm the booze no we're good should
we let's plug dave
good idea hit him hit him i got uh this
comes out
and all right so okay okay so
all right i'll be in nashville this
weekend uh
zany's the 23rd through the 25th i hope
you come out
uh brokerage comedy club in belmore new
york
july uh 30th and 31st good room
uh lex i'm bringing great comics with me
i'm bringing dean
a hashem to that i got ron on hershberg
who's a killer with me the following
weekend in
lexington kentucky hell yeah uh the
fifth through seventh
then in august i've got uh kansas city
missouri
i've got portland oregon i've got royal
oak michigan
then september boston philly
millersville
[ __ ] uh all over uh moon tower for
austin
it's gonna be it's gonna be st louis
helium
all of samurai.com shows every [ __ ]
week we're doing this i'm i'm grateful
to be back out
i know it's nice the road is good people
are loving comedy again which is a real
treat
i'm at the philadelphia helium one of my
all-time favorite clubs
that's gonna be a hot one top five yeah
easily easily then helium buffalo
that'll be fun dayton funny bone
appleton skyline arlington improv
brea improv albany funny bone
west palm beach comedy connection comedy
on
state did you do that yet uh by the time
this is out yes
okay well i can't wait to hear about
that i'm also at zaney's in nashville
rochester richmond funny bone portland
helium
all kinds of damage comedy.com i love it
man check it out get on the patreon
email us at we might be drunk pod
dot or at gmail and uh any packages
oh paige should we open this real quick
patreon.com
we might be drunk pod and the new
youtube channel make sure you get on
that
matt do we have a address for that that
we're gonna use we don't know it yet all
right but just
we'll post it in our stories on
instagram and
uh i'm sure you'll find it just right
it's pretty easy to find
two pack we got a package and then uh
and then uh yeah keep keep emailing us
keep listening
we're gonna open this package on air
before we leave let's hope it's not
weird it's gonna be like a
cease and desist
all right here we go wow this could be
interesting
oh we should say we're starting a bar
here so uh we have a bar
so you want to send us anything wow what
is this i don't know
weird is that everest or is that rainier
okay okay that looks like a rattlesnake
i'm confused maybe this is a riddle
no no no no no no so yeah and you can
remember when you mail us stuff
uh it's at gotham studios 39 west
38th street in new york city should we
who should they address it to matt
god yeah i just got them and though the
hell what is this you're sending us your
screensaver
what is this [ __ ] oh all right
bart work another another mountain hey
we are on repeats already i don't i
don't
understand the snake i'm flattered that
you send us a gift but i don't
understand the snake exactly
you sure this is for us
what the [ __ ] is there a little girl's
pigtail in here too is this a ransom
what the hell is this mark and sam's
drunks
and there's no note i know it would
suffice maybe it's in the patreon maybe
give that a look for an email or
something
oh boy this feels like oh it's like
leathery too the picture oh wow
maybe there's a photographer out there i
mean look they're cool photos i'm not
like gonna knock on them what movie
what's in the box
thank you her your wife's pretty little
head
yeah yeah all right john doe's got the
upper hand feel that that's kind of
weird right
oh that's nice what do you think this is
nice stuff whoever that sent this
uh i guess it's for bar art
canvasonsale.com
northwest 107th street miami florida all
right well maybe this was stuff that was
in the condo
so is this just supposed to be like
american art or some [ __ ] i don't know
yeah all right is that everest where is
everest
the alps no andes
that's a mint where the hell is everest
it sounds american but it ain't it is no
isn't it where is it
i [ __ ] read a book on everest tonight
oh boy
i read that [ __ ] the guy who wrote
into the wild
this is embarrassing wait into the wild
is everest no but
the same author who wrote that book i
[ __ ] read both of those in the
movie great book
i think you're right but now you got to
look it up
k2 the ski gear
no you're right nepal and china wow it's
asian
yeah there was a crazy book on it the
guy wrote into the wild wrote it and
it's like
sherpas and people not making it and
people yeah that's
crazy now they have wi-fi on everest fun
fact
true story because you want to be on
tick-tock when you're taking in the
world's greatest view
well you got to post the gram it's not
the tallest mountain though
i think you're right but everybody talks
about everest it's kind of like how
you know we talk about this comic but he
ain't the funny
all right good [ __ ] well this is a hot
episode thanks for listening
and uh keep uh keep on keeping on
keep on drinking what do you got no
right fine it's tall yeah one of the
parts of the book is they could see the
top but the weather was [ __ ] up it was
like crazy
wow so they were like well that you're
gonna die if you may so you imagine
making it all the way up there and yeah
like this
is probably a bad idea to get to the
absolute top
oh god that's crazy but it's crazy it
was just people who have enough money to
like have a sherpa like you have you
make enough money to just be like
yeah uh i'll just pay you to take me up
right
both of those careers both those lives
are so weird to me
yes one of them is like it's my job to
help
it could be like some [ __ ] financier
it's just like
i want to see the top of everest and
some sherp is like i'm kind of in this
for the love of the game but you're
yeah they couldn't be more different i
didn't know i was part of some rich
douche bags bucket list but yeah but
he's getting paid handsomely i'm sure
the sherpa is the real hero
instead of once for the for the photo op
it's badass
pretty badass and they'll get no love
by the way if we're doing
uh this is a horrible idea for a sketch
mountains on dating apps you know you
got a
k2 hey very tall getting laid
huh all right turn the camera off
i've been drinking you know then you got
some other uh the andes oh you say
you're
3 000 feet you're only 28 you know
yes thank you okay
rockies joke was rocky
we might be drunk we
might be drunk as long as we are hanging
out you know
we might be drunk raise a glass let's
talk [ __ ]
head peeps wrecks and a bit maybe drunk
we might be drunk